Tyler the Creator is here what's up bro
sleepy
yeah man you had a show in jacksonville
last night and you drove like the tampa
that's yeah it's not a light drive I
mean this far it's far enough yes
it's 9:30 in the morning right now you
should be tired well we um we can sleep
on the bus with you know that show was
really good so my body is actually
really tired um I was just telling you
man like you know the new album cherry
bomb obviously dropped it did you
dropped it while you're at Coachella
right yeah he came out like ij4 day
notice to the world and then it just
came out I like eight and I was eating
dinner when it came out and um yeah uh
yeah I feel like man like it's it's it's
really like I've been listening to it
over the last week or so and I the more
I listen to it the more I feel like it's
you know I used to I was kind of when I
first heard it I was still like yeah you
know what I think I like I still like
wolf more than this one but I think it's
definitely your best body work sonically
you've definitely grown a lot man do you
do you feel like that that same
sentiment for a favor it's my best album
you know just from a technical
standpoint um it's a grower to a lot of
you like I mean it's cool and in the
morning listen to it they're like oh
[ __ ] depressed sick it's like you know
everyone has their favorites but this is
so Pharma like how Wes Anderson's best
movie will be the grand butt of his
hotel
but that's not my favorite but I know
from him knowing what he's doing it's
his actual best technical work rather
our favorite is like moonrise kingdom or
whatever so everyone has that with me
but this is um musically this is my best
cuz I figured out what I was trying to
do for sure talk about um obviously uh
Smuckers is the song everybody star
Marquez Kanye's on it little Wayne's on
it little Wayne to me like a 2011 Tyler
maybe not my I wouldn't have thought
that Tyler and little Wayne like you
know I feel like you kind of represent
what an authentic hip-hop artist that
also skates is is yeah I guess to the
non posers that you know and I feel like
a lot of I know I know Wayne's really
kind of dedicate himself to that
the last three or four years I guess
he's not faking the funk by any means
he's always at Tampa skate park here but
uh how did how did that relationship
happen and and you know is that
something that maybe a lot of fans were
caught off-guard by a lot of your core
fans well mom mom a lot of my core fans
understand I like music right so like I
have a year to know where to put what
and I'm when that song came about I was
like damn Wayne was sounding really good
on this the tone of his voice and his
cadence will work perfectly over this
and it worked out yeah straight up um
did you guys
was it a send the mp3 once I positions
one of those I went we yay when he did
but you you were in the you were in the
lab oh yeah yeah at his house and then
with Wayne it was I just sent it and
then he sent some [ __ ] back like three
days later I was like oh my god yeah and
now you did a thing on tomatoes what's
Kanye's house like this tight you
doesn't live too far for me and he has a
sink grass like backyard like a lot of
grass that's what I want
Oh picnics is she there so there's so
many like like to me the album like goes
so many different places what was the
funnest song to make on the album the
funnest or something that kind of like
the most memorable recording process for
like a particular song that kind of
sticks out the brown stains with a
schoolboy q just cuz uh before I looked
at before I recorded that I looked up
some juvenile videos I'm just trying to
see like I always thought he was really
cool just the way he sound it was unique
so I was I was like they only receive an
hour accorded that she yolk then and
then I think my favorite song is either
[ __ ] young which is obviously the
song you have a video out for or but
that sample on Buffalo was crazy oh yeah
yeah I've heard that well isn't that on
it wasn't that on the pristine record
numbers on the board yeah just a sound
bite but I just love I love I love the
way I love to hear like samples that
I've heard before reworked I think it
sounded super dope I kind of
and bullying but like I do like little
voice little voice hits and [ __ ] like
little random chopped up like that yeah
any super dope man um I always hear you
talking about
you want to build skate parks and
buildings and you want to start shooting
films and stuff what is next for you as
far as like you have such a creative
palette man like what's next line I mean
you just put a new album out what are
you gonna work on next this is gonna be
a movie is it gonna be I mean obviously
you gotta be show I'm doing a lot of
[ __ ] for the app that we just released
um there's a lot of cool [ __ ] that's
gonna come out on there but um like
physical creative [ __ ] I don't know
what's next
I don't know this kinda just kind of
comes on it just comes sometimes like
that's a good idea and we don't do it
you mentioned um Wes Anderson earlier
like who is some of your favorite
filmmakers and what's your favorite like
top two or three movies over the last
like ten years
I like Wes are you a coins brothers do
it at all
they're chill they're cool I haven't I
asked us Big Lebowski Smythe yeah that's
what house let's say I haven't seen em
all but from the movies I would have
bought that [ __ ] for your DVD and
brought it home there none of their
movies are about anything which is
amazing yeah for sure
they make full movies about like a
stupid like one stupid situation it just
stretches out for an hour and a half yet
and it's sick um some Paul Thomas
Sanders just uh I love Queen I love
Queen um everybody always holds pulp
fiction up like as I don't like that
Randy so that's what I wanted to ask you
like what's what's your Quinton Flynn
tangos like his best that I feel like
that's when he knew what he was doing
this thing with the West movie I said um
I loved and glorious bastards um so you
would take those two over pulp fiction
yeah Pope fictions I mean like the
characters are cool but like um I
wouldn't watch it again that's crazy
like that's part school when they dig in
a chunk are
cool right when when a dude's getting
[ __ ] in the ass in the back of still
being renamed but other than that I
hated Jackie Brown [ __ ] that movie that
[ __ ] went nowhere yo Jackie Brown was
kind of weak I saw you tweeted yesterday
that you thought Josh Hartnett was Josh
Hartnett nah I'm gonna ask you who you
would bang the first person that come up
and you tweet back
I wouldn't bang but Josh Hartnett is the
faculty my god I never I never saw that
movie in just last week you're lucky
I've asked all that movie and the movies
actually not bad it's okay yeah you know
random who's it like obviously uh
there's there's definitely a lot of love
situations I think you've you know never
strayed away from talking about girls on
your and your music
who's in Tyler the creator's spank bank
the spank bank
give me give me four or five chicks in
the spanking like right now my number
one is Tinashe she's holding down that
number one spot in this Bank Bank um I
still have a thing for Jennifer Lawrence
well hey she's gorgeous she with that
[ __ ] from Coldplay doe then they go
crazy Chris Martin is she still with
that [ __ ] Chris Martin that mean he's
garbage yeah I mean he did upgrade
though he did upgrade from going to tell
true you can't be mad at that
yeah Gwyneth Paltrow's gorgeous um maybe
Gwyneth Paltrow what movies were seeing
recently Shh I don't think she's I don't
know I can't even think of a Gwyneth
Iron Man 3 she was something and I was
just like yelled is Oh [ __ ] is bad oh
my god um random model girls and she do
you follow a lot of other Instagram
thought he's on the on the ground now
that [ __ ] does another for me yeah it's
like it's almost like gross and you see
these [ __ ] like always like in like
Dubai or my last self-esteem like
working out on [ __ ] it like really
yeah like a poster that people people
who work out [ __ ] yeah people who work
out and post video of them working
it's it's the worst man I want to throw
a couple albums at you and I want you to
pick one man hell hath no fury or
college dropout if you had to pick one
that's no fury
it's a good choice that's a good choice
for me to that video changed my life
already platinum or hmm what can I put
up against our clones are clones
even though already platinum got like
three three songs like such a great
album make me feel ignorant one gold
eyes teeth but I wish that I wish that
for Ralph Slim Thug situation we're like
last more yeah like we got a warrant
latinum the actual song is so tight yeah
yeah man I missed that like three or
four year pocket of like Neptune stuff
man when it comes to the new album
Cherry Bomb you put out a bunch of
different artwork but the character that
you that you made yourself as but the
pink face kind of reminds me a crane
from Ninja Turtles have you gotten that
I'm never watched and then Jasper would
know exactly who you're talking about I
never watched Ninja Turtles that's crazy
that makes me feel so [ __ ] old no no
for my generation he just never caught
me like great but now what what is like
explain this like pink dude man and like
like obviously was originally just a
sketch from his bubble gum commercial I
did I'm a fake bubble going I'll just
like bored so I shot a commercial for it
and I just kept and I said I'll just say
hello I start right in my head if I
actually made bubblegum what will be the
character in a logo and how I run it in
things as though I wouldn't stop drawing
that face on random stuff so say I got a
random magazine and then it was a
picture of Gwyneth Paltrow or something
I'll just draw it over fast character
over her body and then I kept doing it
and then I did it to myself and then I
was like well this dude's pretty sick
do you um like Kanye's got Donda which
you know I look has a lot of people will
respect Kanye's taste and visuals and
art and stuff like that can you see her
like you have always consistently have
some of the best artwork videos all that
stuff can you see yourself like starting
something like that to where you kind of
handle all creative stuff right people
can't flog
and that's just like the umbrella which
everything falls under stuff so why has
anybody like some like like rapper who
like has anybody outside who can't ever
hit you like Tyler I need some ideas on
how a lot of stuff but I just decline
because um either a I'm not a fan of
their work and for it to work we have to
respect each other and of course yeah
like mesh or two I just been really busy
but 98% of the time is because I don't
really [ __ ] will do right I know you you
you [ __ ] with Action Bronson the long
way yeah Bronson's mine too yo like the
real Dos Equis guy just like I think
he's like the most interesting man in
the world like he's the lamb he never
tries to be him too cool or not and he's
really just him and what a lot of people
I come across they just try to be cool
guy 24/7 cuz they know his cameras
around but he's just him besides action
who like and besides action or anybody
in your squad
like who's some some of the artists
music that you're bumping in the hip-hop
world over the last year so there's been
some good music like run the jewels got
a dope project you know Freddie Gibbs I
know your I know you and Gibbs are cool
but what's the music that Tyler's been
listening to hip hop wise I know you
have a you know a big musical nothing
really to be honest nothing I like
action stuff yeah and that came out
about mr. wonderful yeah mr. wonderful
doesn't literally hit that I could think
of yeah that's it a lot of people made a
big deal obviously you talked about is I
mean you and um and Kendall Jenner are
friends but the whole Coachella thing
you said that you Spence
[ __ ] that's crazy that that's a big we
went to Buffalo Wild Wings the other day
is some random [ __ ] came up like yo I
don't know the dude's name but he said
[ __ ] kendall Jenner and that was so cool
you're sitting with there I'm no no well
see oh I'm just like is that really news
like oh my god no I'm asking because I
know
you see III think you said that you were
my Allah for Nia has a drought we all
walk and [ __ ] are fully hyped on the
fact someone said [ __ ] Hindu Jenner but
what's the reason why I bring it up is
because uh I know you've spent a lot of
time with her family and they just did
the Bruce Jenner thing last night have
you ever met her pops did you any was a
matter of that did you watch the
interview at all nah do you have any
thoughts on that I don't know this about
then he's that key admit he's
transitioning to a woman and that's so
cool it's pretty crazy
that's actually really tight I'm telling
you man if I could transition to like a
tree or it's just anything I will
[ __ ] do if you could transit if you
could be anything but but but the the
dude that you are if you could
transition into like you said a tree
what would it be man
what would you turn yourself into
obviously besides either a bird or a
Jeep a G yeah that's some redneck dude
you drive me that's some Florida [ __ ]
right I don't know
crocodiles touch me and she'll be sick
that'd be tight mud all over me as dope
he said it I'll be used the way I'm
supposed to use that's funny
oh man um you mentioned the drought I
mean I followed that pretty closely like
I've seen like like pictures from my
2011 they're like now we're [ __ ] up
and the [ __ ] rich white
[ __ ] a Beverly Hills still
using they founds in she you live in
Calabasas in that area not too far um
have you done any have you changed
anything in your life like like I mean
you are you conscious about the way you
use water now yeah it's weird like I
usually turn the shower on and go to a
room of course five minutes later now
it's like thirty seconds they're like
when I brush my teeth I turn the water
off it's like all that stuff that that
when you were in school like they told
you to do like to save water like you
have to do now I'm doing it because it's
like we're actually [ __ ] and then it's
gonna suck when it's at the point in
time where people that could afford it
to have all the water leaving people who
can't afford it without it and it's like
[ __ ] I can't run I'm happy to be on the
other
that but it's gonna suck if that
actually becomes what it is it becomes a
reality out there straight up man
do you watch TV man I feel like like
we're in an age where everybody binge
watches on Netflix and like there's you
know walking down watch what do you
watch Clarence and gumball
okay shows on Cartoon Network that
Cartoon Network I want to be you know
show my kid my kid rocks with that show
those two shows are fired
you're not like you bet you don't ever
get into like Walking Dead or like yeah
so I got into was freaks and geeks and
before that was Breaking Bad
Oh Breaking Bad yes um better call Saul
to spin-off not bad I haven't only
watched half episode um I have to see
what's up with that I don't know it's
nothing else that catches my eye
what a six-story all right at least um
what's crazy about the album man that I
thought was really dope was the fact I
know you've always spoke highly of Roy
Ayers and um like like the guy who kind
of brought me up in the game who's like
a og DJ would like always like give me
all his like like like records that like
all the Warriors records that were
sampled in hip-hop and I just thought it
was dope you got him you got him
involved on the album how like how do
you sue somebody who is you know how
does a creator this young hip-hop dude
who a lot of people perceive to be you
know extreme and maybe off-putting if
you're an old you know it may be a part
of the older generation how does that
conversation start with Roy Ayers like
like like well the smarter people the
more intelligent people who don't just
look at the surface it makes the most
sense no I think musically yeah I'm just
curious like how that that dialogue
starts like you just have my people hit
up his people and then we speak on the
phone and he sees her my head that and I
know where his head's at because I'm a
fan of the ously and we go from there
and he hears what I'm trying to get his
input on and he's a fan of it and it's
it probably catches him a little bit off
guard too like oh wow this is amazing
cuz he
we love what we did and um it's cool and
it's like my favorite it's my most proud
thing that I produced so far just from
the way that it's um the structure of
the song how I layered everyone how you
know things like that you know hopefully
that opens people's ears because a lot
of kids or people never listen to music
like that there's Eric Lee raps so when
they hear stuff like that they can't
they can't grasp the concept of how
amazing it is cuz growing up they didn't
listen to that they don't know what jazz
or fusion is or whatever so they're
quick to just throw it off but hopefully
me even introducing them to something
different like that will allow them to
explore and open their sound palette up
yeah straight up um
[ __ ] young great video great song
Thanks um is that for more like an
actual situation that you like went
through where yeah this was like under a
shorty lie like that's I feel like
Tigers should have listened to that song
every not this album which is cool for
me because I'm gonna hiding behind a
character just saying brightly [ __ ] like
the other albums every line and song on
here is just real life and just how
really feeling like that particular
situation like you just like that's like
a real situation like I was just like
would be sick song in the write about
you know get all my 70 [ __ ] yeah and I
made a song about it and um it's uh
that's a taboo type like a situation
people don't talk abut it's not a
situation a lot of rappers will talk
about yeah but that I'm honest and I'm
not ashamed
like I'll let you know about myself so I
wrote a song about it and um they came
out pretty cool um you have some
crazy-ass fans man uh has there ever
been a situation that you've been in
where you've been scared like where
you've come across somebody so hyper
like psychotic or you know only times
some super thottie Pippen at the hotel
rumors he tried to give me a razor and
wanted me to sign his arm and he had
like dumb cuts like every gave you a
razor he was like he was earnest and I
grabbed it just thinking it's a pen just
oh that's weird
you know bodyguards like [ __ ] punch
dead
and everyone was sketched out like what
the [ __ ] that's crazy vid a.m. I
remember a a couple years ago I remember
seeing footage of you a super-hype at
the Gucci Mane show in LA are you like a
fan of any of the new Atlanta stuff it's
like the migos or future any of that
kind of [ __ ] that's that's kind of
popping that's that's kind of taking
left off they do but I'm not I don't
really listen to much yeah it's just not
what my ear there's just not what I
listen to but uh future does have a song
called transform you I think that I like
and I like move that dope I am it's
pretty cool I move that dope said I mean
that's pretty you know Pharrell Gabe or
P came out what I don't know I wish it
wasn't at the end of the song cuz like
when you play it in the club I got to
skip ahead to front it's actually
perfect no I mean yeah as a DJ verse on
there is actually 10 out of 10 I was
listening to that and listening to the
cadence of everyone how different it was
especially casino the last verse at
first I hated it I do it again but why
is this casino guy at a song with mirela
know what he was doing and just his just
the way he was writing and then even
pushes rush is crazy in their future
women like writing the [ __ ] the the
the under like the low end of it that
shit's meant to how they all like
exactly different yo you got a naked
chick on your shirt right now who are
you a connoisseur of the exotic cinema
like do you have like a top view like
porn [ __ ] that you go to on the porn
like your key [ __ ] like you know what
I like this [ __ ] called Tanner maze
when I was younger
Hannah maze yes little white [ __ ] um
this is like it's this light-skinned
black girl that's bad skin diamond she's
my nosh she not like no Instagram
thoughts
no no skin she's actually in diamond is
a real star did you look at her getting
[ __ ] and you're like yo yo you could
be doing some things
doing something so productive like I put
you in a video [ __ ] up oh that's funny
damn I gotta find her name I forgot it
yeah now I'm intrigued man I mean I like
she's cute like she should not be doing
that you feel so guilty there's a fee
there's like two or three chicks like
that we're like why don't like what
happened what are you doing why did your
dad after molest you like what you need
to go find a rich [ __ ] be a doctor so
like them one of them like you know
she's gonna be bad as [ __ ] was she 45 -
you gotta [ __ ] with Skin Diamond bro
that is the one on the next time you go
to the next time you find yourself in
front of a laptop and you know you about
to do what you do Skin Diamond my gig
diamond that name I sound like a
procedure she's like a like a like a
she's like a light-skinned black chick
is a Botox procedure you could get or
something I don't know skin down he's
bad [ __ ] lots tattoos gross I'm full
off like fully off that tattoos
disgusting she's like a Rihanna like
how'd she look sound like Rihanna a lot
of people compared to real like that on
Clancy that's what's up man we'll look
tonight the show is gonna be live man if
you haven't since [ __ ] venue better
not suck you look [ __ ] I hate outside
like this you're at Janis live it's not
gonna rain well it's Florida you never
know it might rain but I've been to a
lot of shows of this venues to do venue
I like the venue Janis live is where
he'll be at um and if you haven't got
your tickets yet you know catfish shows
are always fun no but well I said the
same thing about Miami too until I
played that [ __ ] outside venue we got
to get on that you got a got a free
check before every venue that makes sure
it's not an amphitheater some [ __ ]
brunch grass section of a hotel or
something if um if a fan a lot of uh
it's like I especially like your boy
Action Bronson any fan that gets on
stage it's like the the straight WM you
have treatment if a fan happens to make
his way up on stage and Atari the
creator show is he gonna get chucked off
like but not by me
not by
yeah but by someone yeah by someone stay
your ass in the crowd or they usually
just jump back in the crowd
what show was it where you got on stage
and I like people like I forget who it
was it didn't know who you were
was it the Gucci baby okay yeah he told
me to come up and then when I got up
there cuz I when I go see shows I like
watch from the crowd
yeah man then I get on stage in his
security grabs me by my neck and throws
me literally but I land on my feet
it was sight and I'm like what the
[ __ ] Gucci Mane side come back and
then I go up and it was tight yeah it's
crazy being like in I mean I'm in the
music industry obviously you're a
musician we get desensitized to to like
[ __ ] man like watching like rap concerts
it's like it's like harder for me I've
seen so many man it's like I've been
there too many rap shows I've seen
Bronson I seen Gucci I'm in the Walker
I've been the anj and I saw a little B
and that little being
I saw little Viet was that pay paid was
it pay dues and same time I see many oh
I seen dips that I paid dues after mine
and yeah that's about it
have you heard any of the these I know
you're a big em fan there's like a
couple like new em versus have dropped
in the last couple weeks he had a soma
tec-9 that was kind of crazy and then I
have not heard about yo they got a new
record that's kind of nuts
it's weird I heard the yellowwood claims
gonna kill me heart the yellow will
phone and Marshalls [ __ ] Kate like by
little has it but that beat I'm not I'm
not a fan of like our show like I was
listening to like [ __ ] he tone down the
yelling he still has it
yeah he could just like get rid of
Skylar Grey like I feel like Skylar
Grey's [ __ ] up his last two albums
yeah like yo man with these damn ballads
he tried try jazz or just go fool left
field and just give us like if we don't
have the [ __ ] up accent on relapse
week he comes back with Skylar Grey on
every song [ __ ] up accident relapses
are [ __ ] amazing out it is but the
accent is 9 out of 10 the action
actually not only a song
that [ __ ] the the beats on there's
good six and a half out of ten we've
never heard from dr. dre sang song and
dancing should we've never heard from
dre the flow I'll stay wide awake from a
flow perspective not one rapper ever
will be able to [ __ ] touch that the
way that he mimicked like the way that
he flips syllables to rhyme with words
that never run is out of it's fun it's
better than encore retelling and better
than that covering from deja vu you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding me you gotta be
a nice stand I will stand by that I will
forever stand by relapse being cuz the
first time I heard he Eminem Fame like
die hard the first time I heard it I was
like [ __ ] wack in that [ __ ]
I start listening to it and seeing what
he was doing oh my god go listen to stay
wide awake and I got every listen to
relapse man and listen to this story
telling the same song and dance it
sounds like I don't but it's not I mean
this is a good album it's it's it's
probably it's just best album since the
Eminem Show
I think marshmallows Opie's the best and
then much of my the LP and relapse are
my favorites okay yeah a lot of [ __ ]
just and I feel like being turned off by
the accent his arm is a cop-out sonic
can't listen yeah even though I get it
like your voice is important I get just
keep your hat audience and see that's
why it make like him being that quick
that character really makes the songs
like goose they wide awake the flowing
that deja vu how personal he got with
his drug habits hiding it from his
daughter is like you kind of cringe it's
like watching a sex scene in a movie
like [ __ ] dude and then even beautiful
even though I got that corny ass sample
you could really see he's sad were you
pretty disappointed with the Marshall
Mathers LP - it was very I thought it
was yeah oh god oh no it's a couple
songs I don't front it was a song
there's there's some good records on
there but he has
don't front that didn't make the album
it was just like I haven't heard a way
that came out the same week it's a it
goes over buckshot is that what it's
called
yeah brainless is fire book it's a song
called don't front look it up and he's
just going in like [ __ ] is sick that's
what's up man we'll look tonight you
will be a Janis live everybody go get
your tickets if anybody hasn't seen you
live can I see this they're still kind
of just like some random Joe this let me
see what they play this is though that
is the [ __ ] that we play on the
radio garbage garbage those all three
sound the same that's easy you have to
you have to talk about each garbage
[ __ ] garbage what's the worst song on
that list every song don't give me one
except truffle butter cuz Wayne [ __ ]
body dad give me one the worst song on
that list that we're playing right now
um what is see you again that's the new
wit song from the ferry soundtrack I
learned it is cool
ayo our hands on deck what is that all
these songs sound alike it's so crazy it
is remember being younger and listening
to the radio and the songs that they
will play all had their own sound so you
could gauge like that's a Timbaland beat
that's no yeah it's a Pharrell be
necessarily yeah and it opened now it's
like every how everybody's mustard or
sounds like but y'all play this [ __ ]
yeah a look man don't sit control at
least just throw something in there
that's just like listen kids don't grow
up being [ __ ] robots bro is so much
good [ __ ] out there and y'all play the
same 30 mega songs everybody it's [ __ ]
up look ya'll in control listen this is
let me speak in my defense Wow for 94.1
request [ __ ] that
listen the miss in my defense I am NOT
the program director every day I get to
play a new joint of the day that I
choose and I play whatever the [ __ ] I
want and then it's always an odd shitty
song suck but there's so many sheep out
there that that a while you play in a
bunch there's just like oh I like it or
if everyone else likes to saw know that
everyone's like oh I guess it must be
good and then these [ __ ]
continue to make horrible [ __ ] all these
songs on here
they didn't even write none of these
people could play a [ __ ] instrument
what is this song about nothing nothing
and y'all [ __ ] play this [ __ ]
although I think earned it by the
weekends cool song I I never really
listened to his music until like two
weeks ago two weeks ago it's weird I'm I
kind of enjoy you know the Wiegand is
asking for like an astronomical amount
of money to do concerts right now like
we just asked how much he would do a
show for I want to say it was like north
of 250 racks
he's fight for that like my G oh you are
not who the [ __ ] you think you are Kanye
West reindeer yeah and it's like Sunday
nights we know we this is what Sunday
nights where we play Tyler the Creator
no Pearl and all that I don't know that
song but they was playing the race
trummer
record in this record Stewart I actually
like race swimmers they play like one
three six and then their interview or
their energy is incredible them kids are
like dopest [ __ ] they're fun is she
dancing like a stripper or some [ __ ]
this is cool
you didn't answer my question that's the
thing I've only heard only the only song
I heard on here is all day by eight
earned it by the weekend and truffle
butter by Nicki Minaj that's the only
song you're speaking on these songs so
negatively and you haven't even heard
them they could be incredible don't even
want a composition don't let you say
that the artists names for a lot of
these titles but I'm smart enough and
aware enough that all and obviously
you've heard trap for trap Queen right
Betty what I don't know probably not it
doesn't sound like anything that I'm
into yep I not know district it's called
trap killing it what like literally
let's be a hundred percent honest from
these artists and these song titles I
could fully tell that these songs are in
a similar vein yeah you're right I mean
a lot of them are like 98 beats per
minute and if it's not produced by
mustard it sounds like it's produced by
mustard that's so crazy
and uh that sucks and then there's like
you know some of a few
mother sprinkled in and then a pitbull
song hmm oh man this is I wonder what
are your thoughts on an artist like
pitbull because like I was making
braised he's making a [ __ ] lot of
money man do you but it's like the I
mean look
everyone has their spot you know
everyone has has their thing has a
voyeur feel yeah I'm not hating on oh
I'm filling their void you [ __ ] do
that I'm just saying it's so much just
like being a radio station I just think
they should just okay these five songs
sound exactly a light let's try to play
to that I don't know there is some
[ __ ] much I just don't get why it's
the same [ __ ] in this case you um
actually I saw you tweet that that our
future radios coming right yeah I'll
make up my own radio station now is that
separate from what's on - well it's on -
but it's just me it's not it's just I
hand paints like five hundred songs that
and is that gonna be like is that gonna
be a part of the app yeah that's that we
don't have to so if you want to hear
where my ears that you could go on this
so is punk is it is his rap is that
already up no it's not next week okay
and what's the app called people come
golf media it's a big G with a yellow I
mean it's a big yellow box with a G in
the middle and is this is free app yeah
yeah for the most part there's some
stuff on there you can pay for yeah get
some cool thing is a lot cuz I feel like
a lot of artists have apps but like they
really don't like apply themselves to
the apps I don't like calling the act
cuz it's more of a network we're like
original content shows just a bunch of
[ __ ] that's only on there are you gonna
um do something on TV can you see
yourself trying to trying to do another
show besides Lord or squad on the on the
tube um like maybe something that's
that's a not away from the sketch thing
like I don't know maybe from a sheet
from my unless someone's like hey here's
a check yeah but that the thing is we my
god that's what I made this thing so I
don't have to go through no one if I
want to put if I want to have a show
have a hundred creative constraint
creative control which I do now but I
don't have anyone in the in my ear you
know being weird
I could do it I can do whatever I want
here that's dope man well look I think
you're like one of the most refreshing
shining stars in music man like you're
true to yourself and you know in 10
years man you know we'll look at like
you how we look at Kanye now I think you
know I'm saying yeah I think I think not
to yourself fool myself off like in
years to come people will see how
important I was just from a level of
just bringing something like just
bringing myself to the thing just doing
what I felt was right do you feel like
like I brought up Kanye cuz I feel like
um Kanye like you're outspoken he's
outspoken do you like kind of uh is that
someone who you kind of relate to
because I feel like in in essence he's
really just like fighting for the good
cause man that's just being creative in
like and and putting art first its
people his people who's on the same
wavelength and me and him are one of
them were me and Kanye on the same
wavelength when it comes to like you
know thoughts and stuff and I don't know
we just like making things and just want
to want our voices to be heard and same
same thing he might be arguing for is
just like how I think all these songs
are not even a big you know if you [ __ ]
with these song school but like just
show people difference yes my great
thing is so much stuff out there I'm
gonna even I'm learning the [ __ ]
start eating just not waffles and bacon
I'm trying different I had alligator
every day and I mean yeah it was it was
far alligator and I was just like
[ __ ] like why not why not at least
give it a chance yeah you know just
being younger a lot of things I gave
chances I got made fun of for and now a
lot of that [ __ ] is cool which is just
weird cuz I'm saying [ __ ] who used to
be right well no you're right cuz I
remember like even as a kid like dude
like if if you were like like I grew up
in I mean your boy plants might not grow
up in Mesa was like a lot of Mormons and
white dudes and you know like there
wasn't like like black skater kids like
that was like weird you know what I'm
saying
no Pharrell in like The Neptunes were
popping like it still wasn't like it
wasn't like accepted you know I'm saying
it's a whole it's a whole group of pink
you know where big-ass clothes in like
yeah I just want people will judge you
for rocking van like if you are a hip
hop kid rocket vans like in high school
[ __ ] will look at you sideways
this middle school I'll just remember
all that but it's cool that it's cool
now and people are opening up to things
and I just think music is one of them
just just so people can know when I get
wanye from boys to men what I'm trying
to do cuz I don't know it's [ __ ] boys to
man is wait a minute the first tape I
ever had but it's people who don't know
what that is because all I hear is
[ __ ] these [ __ ] damn this [ __ ]
aw damn day at least give [ __ ] some
history when you but that's just me
being a geek now I feel you listen man
at the end of the day I could give you
the back history who wrote it the damned
publishing so straight up I geek out but
I just like feeding information cuz
there's so much you can learn from
different people if people have not seen
you live before if there's like someone
who's like 50/50 on coming and seeing
you tonight man like you know explain to
people what they're gonna be missing out
man I don't know what the [ __ ] they
missing out on cuz it's what you into
man
I don't know you might come to Haiti cuz
it's not what you ain't rightly check it
out I guess you know some people like it
I have fun on stage and that's like
you're a mosh pit at every show I'm for
the most part because I've been in a
play in a minute man like we used to
actually get the punk is at the shows in
my yeah used to get actual like cuz I
when I was a kid we used to go like I
used to go to like punk shows and like
you would always have you'd have to get
out either window skinhead jumped in or
the big-ass Native American do jumped in
are there that gnarliest cuz if you fall
they're the first to pick you up this
yeah them natives will lay you lay a
white boy it's like they're like they're
like releasing all the aggression of
their oh absolutely on to the white
anyway
yo tonight you know what I'm you going
anybody know what time he goes on he'll
be on stage I'm 10 P hours I say I'm
assuming around ten so make sure you got
anybody opening up
I don't like people I'm [ __ ] uh I'm
selfish so what happens between like
seven and ten is just a DJ seven and ten
like I'm saying like like the doors open
if your is open people stand there and
they get drawn a [ __ ] wait they may
not go onstage and then I go home one of
the worst things about hip-hop shows is
when like there's like 25 local acts on
it it's like [ __ ] one I don't want to be
a dick with no one wants to [ __ ] see
that nobody you got a build your name up
first and then give fans like I don't
have you ever list like one like I'm
sure you always have people passing you
CDs do you ever ever give a [ __ ] to
listen to listen to a couple one of them
was pretty decent but always say um if
I'm really supposed to hear it I will
yeah that's what I tell everybody
crossed some some kids [ __ ] some not
even kids like my age some band from New
York [ __ ] and it was tight I said I
really like it you know I feel like they
they're probably they'll be hype to know
I heard it
well yo uh tonight go see the show
tickets are on sale there's still some
tickets left and we actually have I got
five pairs of tickets I want to be given
away so let's do that right now triple
eight four two nine zero ninety-four one
I got some Tyler the Creator tickets the
album is out now
what's the next video coming out off the
out play some clips or something this is
raps they play clear today or uh play uh
I'm gonna play [ __ ] young I got
[ __ ] young that's cool and I got
Smuckers I cleaned up some others cuz I
play your suckers play and play yo man
you gotta like like like I know there's
only a few of us like me Rosenberg
there's like - and Seattle but when you
put an album out for [ __ ] sake please
make a radio version every single
version everytime you put five days and
all they say was - song like I want the
whole album like last Sunday we played
four songs off the album and had to
clean them up it's very meticulous thank
you but no it's think cuz I don't get
radio play to say I know you don't but
if you guys you know
it's been like four different people
begging me for cleans and it makes me
happy it's like finally like yeah but um
yeah I never bother cuz it's like what's
the [ __ ] point but um now people are
asking so it's like okay hell yeah if I
could if I could get this song on the
way cuz I remember the songs that shaped
me I heard on the radio when I was
younger and that opened a whole new door
for me so I feel like it'll be some
[ __ ] ten-year-old who will hear that
and just be like they'll either hear you
or they'll hear ya so hopefully they
hear me and they're just like what is
yours they'll hear goin down for real
from Flo Rida I don't even know what
that is
anyway man I appreciate the talk go get
the album it's uh it's it's out right
now it's it's in stores now right now
why is a target hold like carry the
target they're [ __ ] communists and
they hate black people what happened
with that
yo every I tried to go by Action Bronson
zelma target
he's on Atlantic they didn't had of
course cuz Action Bronson is black
they hate blacks and they're [ __ ]
communists and they support terrorism so
[ __ ] target so [ __ ] target um uh Best
Buy though you can go get it the best
Best Buy our Loki communist but they're
starting to open up because that I saw
like a lot of fans were standing there
in the back album was supposed to come
out to 28th April we got which is in 3d
outward that oh [ __ ] the album has been
shipped so I'm like okay I'm telling my
fans hey cuz my fans love buying
physical so I'm like hey go and get the
physical at these stores but it was only
like for Best Buy's that decided to put
it out out the whole country so it's a
lot of fans who's like hey B you have
this CD and the people that work at Best
Buy if it's not gonna do releases we
don't have it but my favorite per system
and don't take no for an answer they're
like yo go to the back and check so they
go in the back and bring out one copy
instead of putting all of them out with
all the artwork and oh yeah with
everything sweat but I mean on this one
the 28th it'll be I mean hopefully it'll
be hopefully to be everywhere I probably
[ __ ] up ever being at Target because
they're [ __ ] communist and um
hopefully Best Buy likes me still it's
[ __ ] up cuz people don't even go to I
went to Best Buy the other day in this
CD section it specify is so yeah
and they said there used to be like a
hip-hop section and now it's just like
one section it's a best buy on my 14th
birthday have found Wonderland by kalise
which was only released in the UK so
they even had imports coming there now
used to work at Best Buy we used to get
some like fly like indie [ __ ] just so
much I just used to be lost in the music
section and now it's like a small set
missed our records and gift cards and
washer and dryer yeah and a lot of
cities don't have out like stores you
could buy CDs so yeah there's very few
like like where I'm from there's like
Ziya records out here there's really
nothing like that we have a meal in LA
which is like the spot just like they
have if you put out any vinyl on Record
Store Day not vinyl for Cherry Bomb is
coming like soon my couple are you going
through Jack Black for that [ __ ] because
I know he does a lot of the vinyl
production for I don't know not Jack
Black's awesome now listen the ball in
the Biscay it's number eight off of
elephant 2004 and uh that song really
shaped taped a lot for you yeah that's
what's up man Tyler the Creator tonight
Jana sly appreciate you bro yes I don't
know what say before you go say one
thing I don't know say whatever you want
to Gazeta cherry bomb is out it's an
amazing record just listen to it
it's loud you got to do something like
you got a dry fast or skydiver that [ __ ]
you don't just sit and listen again you
[ __ ] go do something when you listen
to that [ __ ] don't sit around yelling
[ __ ] target bus are here we got that and
establish that yeah life's great I'm
smiling word up man appreciate it right
yeah